IT WAS ROBERT MUELLER HIM SELF A
REQUESTED LETTER.
OUCH.
THE MEDIA MOB ROASTED HIM AGAIN.
HIS REACTION, FORMER CONGRESSMAN
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, A GUY WHO
NEVER LOST CASE IS A PROBLEM
PROSECUTOR, TREY.
ACTUALLY THOUGHT ABOUT DOING IT
FOR THE WHOLE HOUR BECAUSE I
HAVE THAT MANY QUESTIONS BUT I'M
TRYING TO GIVE A FLAVOR.
YOU'VE GOT 5 MINUTES, YOU BETTER
GET YES OR NO QUESTIONS IN AND
LAY OUT THE FACTS FOR THE BODY'S
BROADER AUDIENCE, IN MY OPINION.
>> YEAH, YOU NEED TO START IT
TWO WEEKS AGO AND YOU NEED TO
HAVE AN OBJECTIVE BEAUTY NEEDS
TO HAVE A PURPOSE.
5 MINUTES GOES BY QUICKLY, YOU
ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
COVER ALL OF THOSE TRANCHES YOU
AND I TALKED ABOUT LAST TIME I
WAS ON YOUR SHOW.
BUT JUST KEEP IN MIND, MUELLER
FOUND SOME THINGS, YOU CAN GO
THERE, HE DIDN'T FIND SOMETHING,
YOU CAN GO THERE.
HE DIDN'T BOTHER TO LOOK FOR
CERTAIN THINGS, YOU CAN GO THER
THERE.
THE ISSUE OF THE BIAS WITHIN THE
INVESTIGATION AND THEN YOU HAVE
ANOTHER CATEGORY, LEGAL ISSUES,
IT'S INTERESTING TO ME THE
WHETHER OR NOT YOU CAN EVEN
OBSTRUCT AND ON PREDICATED
INVESTIGATION PRETTY CAN
CERTAINLY RESIST AN UNLAWFUL
ARREST.
SO WITH THE INVESTIGATION ON
PREDICATED, THEN CAN YOU
ACTUALLY EVEN OBSTRUCT SOMETHING
THAT NEVER SHOULD HAVE BEGUN?
THOSE ARE FIVE TRANCHES THAT YOU
GOT TO BE PREPARED AND I'M SURE
BOTH SIDES WILL BE FOR TOMORROW.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU, IF
YOU HAVE 5 MINUTES, IS IT BETTER
TO ASK SHORTER QUESTIONS TO GET
THE FACTS OUT?
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THERE IS AN
ENTIRE AUDIENCE THAT NOTE THAT
DOES NO HILLARY PAID FOR RUSSIAN
LIES.
TO COMMIT FRAUD AGAINST THE FISA
COURT, BUT IT IS IT PREDICATED
ON UNVERIFIED MATERIAL THAT
PEOPLE LIKE JAMES COMEY SWEAR
WAS VERIFIED.
HOW DOES HE NOT INVESTIGATE THAT
BUT HE HAS TIME FOR TAXING
MEDALLIONS AND FEDERAL
VIOLATIONS, FORMER CONGRESSMAN,
TREY GOWDY?
>> WELL, HE'S NOT GOING TO HELP
YOU MUCH.
BUT, HE DOESN'T WANT TO BE
THERE.
HE MADE THAT VERY CLEAR IN HIS
PRESS CONFERENCE BUT HE DOESN'T
EVEN WANT TO TESTIFY.
HE'S NOT GOING TO DEVIATE FROM
THEIR REPORT FOR TWO REASONS,
QUITE FRANKLY A GREAT NUMBER
ONE, PROSECUTORS ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO DEVIATE FROM THEIR
CHARGING DECISION OR NONCHARGING
BUT HERE'S THE REAL REASON.
LET'S ASSUME HE DOES SAY
SOMETHING NEW OR DIFFERENT
TOMORROW.
YOUR FOLLOW-UP QUESTION IS GOING
TO BE, WHY THE HILL WAS THAT NOT
IN YOUR REPORT?
ANYTHING NEW OR DIFFERENT OR
SPECIAL OR INTERESTING THAT HE
SAYS TOMORROW --
>> Sean: IF HE HAD TIME FOR
FARAH AND LOMA APPLICATIONS, HOW
DOES HE AVOID A RUSSIAN LOST
DOSSIER FULL OF LIES THAT WERE
USED TO SPY ON A PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE IN 2016, HOW DO YOU
AVOID THAT ISSUE?
>> HE DOES NEED TO BE ASKED
ABOUT WHAT HE DID NOT LOOK INTO.
I THINK THE ANSWER IS GOING TO
BE IS GOING TO BLAME
ROD ROSENSTEIN.
HE'S GOING TO SAY LOOK, YOU CAN
CALL THE GUY HIRED ME BUT I
WOULD SPEND ALMOST ALL OF MY
TIME ASKING HIM ABOUT THINGS HE
DID NOT BOTHER TO LOOK FOR SUCH
AS THE ORIGIN OF THIS
INVESTIGATION IN JUNE OF 2016.
THAT'S WHERE I WOULD SPEND MY
TIME.
>> Sean: I WANT TO KNOW WHY HE
DIDN'T DELVE INTO A PHONY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER THAT WAS SPREAD
TO THE AMERICAN ELECTORATE ON
THE EVIL OF AN USED TO SPY
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR BY HILLARY
ON THE OPPOSITION PARTY